est ce qu'un jour tu vas me draguer will
j'attends le bon moment
un de ses jours alors c'est pas pour
rien que j'attends le bon moment joe
rouge de drague il ya plus de marche
arrière possible
je n'aurais personne d'autre jusqu'à la
fin de ma vie j'aimerais personne
d'autre jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
si j'attends le bon moment à bille sais
pas ce que ça va être le moment le plus
important de toute ma vie
alors je voudrais m'assurer de faire ça
bien
[Musique]
la vie nous fait des niches elle nous
balade elle dépeint en héros celui qui
pourrait être scellé rats héros ou
scélérat bonsoir ça les scélérats où
iront les premiers rôles de notre
histoire pourrait se révéler simple
figurant dans un film beaucoup plus
vaste voilà
whitney et us f1 je vais une vie
grandiose et en iran
on devrait se marier ça fait moins d'un
an comme un ensemble je sais ouais j'ai
fait preuve d'une retenue prodigieuse
pendant tout ce temps numéro
charles quint m
jeudi le pont
je n'ai pas tout à fait à mes pour être
aimé un standard
[Musique]
on l'a
ne le prends pas mal mais j'ai toujours
voulu que mon fils épouse une femme dont
les parents seraient morts pour pas
avoir à partager les petits enfants
mamans oh ça va comprendre ce que je dis
[Musique]
c'est tellement bizarre qu'un événement
fortuit bien avant ma naissance
et puis transformer ma vie
vous êtes heureux qu'il se soit produit
dans ce mot gauche dis donc je serais
pas surpris
dans ce monde
[Musique]